here in the studio now it's great to
have you with us now you took a little
time today to outline why you thought
these plans wouldn't work because of the
state of funding and resources the
Department of Health has said that
you're being overly negative and
pessimistic you know I wish I was being
overly pessimistic all I'm doing is
reflecting the reality out there which
the government is also aware of that we
have a reduction in uptake for young
doctors wanting to be GPS and one in
five of those training to G to be GPS
are going to be wanting to work abroad
and on top of that one in three GPS
surveyed are intending to retire in the
next five years so we're simply
reflecting a very harsh reality that we
run the risk of having fewer gp's rather
than more and we've got to do something
about making general practice to
stabilize it make it a job that young
doctors want to to enter and to retain
the GP workforce we've got so that's
what I'm saying we need to be doing you
know really focusing on the pressures
rather than making these promises for
several years hence and of course it
takes ten years to train a GP so in the
meantime we've clearly got a crisis
already patients what appointments they
want to come in and say yes they think
we can't so it's a water-filled and the
real answer is firstly to focus exactly
on as you say the pressures we've got of
far too few GPS and one of the things we
can do is try and ensure that patients
use the service appropriately there are
other services can be used like
pharmacists we need to reduce a lot of
the bureaucracy and pressures on GPS we
believe there are several thousand
appointments a day that are wasted on
purely bureaucratic reasons why patients
really do not need to come and see us
because other parts of system are asking
us to to sign forms etc so there are
ways to reduce pressure but some would
say that the Reutimann's crisis stems
all the way to 2004 we saw that
contracted GPS chain which meant that
you could opt out of offering out of our
services and that's when things really
started to become problematic you know
no GPS opted out because you know if a
patient needs a GP at 2:00 in the
morning the a GP will see a patient more
than half of practices already offer
extended
our sessions and there's a GP service
seven days a week for any urgent patient
what we really need to make sure is that
service is properly resourced that NHS
one-one-one knows how to use that
service properly there are far too many
patients going to casualty through poor
advice from the telephone helpline so we
do still provide a 24-hour service seven
days a week what we don't have is enough
day time appointments for the volume of
care we're seeing you know 40 million
more patients see a GP now compared to
five years ago every year you know that
is the largest increase in any sector of
the NHS and we have seen a reduction in
number of GPS in the NHS workforce and
yet the pressures are likely to increase
even further we know that people are
getting older they got more complex
problems as well your members are going
to be asked longer probably for not much
more money if any more money at all what
do you do you don't think it really is
nothing to do with money it's just
simply we don't have enough GPS as we
speak now but they are unlikely to be
asked to do more and that's our concern
that if you start to stretch gp's
further you will basically start to see
GPS providing sort of shift work rather
than continuity and in fact it will take
us away from the ilist in society are
the frail elderly patients for whom it's
not a case of how many days we open they
need their GP to be there for them would
you advise your members perhaps to take
industrial action in streamis if it
comes to it no I mean this is not about
in just what I would like is to have a
sensible dialogue with the government
they want to have an NHS with a strong
general practice foundation where
patients can go and see a GP and have
time with their GP that's exactly what
GPS want so what we really need to do is
get our heads together and come up with
a workable solution and what we're
saying is having these ideas about
opening seven days whilst the government
itself says that we're 5000 gp's short
is not the way to proceed so that's what
we're looking forward to doing those
nightfall thank you very much into